impeachment lawyers take questions from
Republicans and Democrats Alan
Dershowitz finds himself under fire
after explaining the nature of
impeachable activity and Republicans
Mull more witnesses i'm ben shapiro this
is the ben shapiro show this show is
sponsored by expressvpn stop putting
your online data at risk how many times
I gotta tell you this get protected and
expressvpn calm / Ben ok so tomorrow is
decision day big Friday vote expected on
whether Republicans will allow further
witnesses it is up in the air as to how
this goes
I mean it's absolutely unclear according
to the New York Post president Trump's
impeachment defense team expects a
Friday cliffhanger when senators vote on
whether to call witnesses in Trump's
trial if Democrats find for Republicans
to vote for witnesses the trial could
stretch until March if they fail Trump
would likely be acquitted now I think
it's a bit of an exaggeration I think
that if the Republicans decide to allow
witnesses then basically they allow like
two witnesses I think it's probably john
bolton maybe Mick Mulvaney and that's it
I think they say everybody who already
testified already have their testimony
we don't need to cut we don't need to
have room Gordon Sunland again it would
be like Joey maybe hunter Biden and John
Bolton and like Mick Mulvaney and that's
it so no I don't think this is going to
stretch for another month just to just
to hash out all of the witness activity
Trump confident mark Meadows told the
New York Post he doesn't believe there
will be clarity on the outcome until
Friday of this week right now there are
basically three senators who are fairly
certain to vote in favor of more
witnesses that would be Lisa Murkowski
of Alaska that would be Mitt Romney of
Utah and that'd be Susan Collins of
Maine some Republican senators according
to the New York Post were optimistic
after the McConnell more Kowski talk
which followed a conference meeting of
senators on Tuesday when McConnell said
he didn't yet have the votes to block
witnesses Murkowski was tight-lipped
after meeting with McConnell telling
reporters I had a meeting with leader
McConnell but I'm not gonna talk to you
about it she said I've been talking with
the folks in the cloakroom about what
the universe is to see how we can
supplement that with regard to witnesses
senator Roger wicker of Mississippi told
the New York Post that the feeling when
Republicans was quote-unquote pretty
good he said obviously we need to make a
decision at this point whether to drag
the foregone conclusion out for another
four to six weeks we know what the
outcome is just a question of how long
it's going to last and Senator Richard
Shelby Republican of Alabama now here is
the here's the problem I mean seriously
if you all believe this
thing that I believe right I said this
yesterday on the show if you believe
that the impeachment outcome is a
foregone conclusion because John Bolton
is not gonna get up and testify he's
just not going to get up and testify
that President Trump said explicitly to
him
I want you condition Ukraine aid I'm
then making up information about Joe
Biden for purposes of 2020 which is the
only thing that would be impeachable
here if that's not the case then why not
get all of this out in the open now
because otherwise it's just gonna leak
right we're just gonna have more leaks
and then it's not just gonna implicate
Trump like look at accent Trump Trump is
Teflon it more than Teflon Trump is kind
of a mud monster in the sense that if
you throw more mud at him he's already
made of mud - who cares he's made of mud
look there's more mud on him whatever
that's how everybody has treated Trump
since the beginning and rightly so
because nothing is new in the world of
Trump them everything is baked into that
cake if there is sugar there is caramel
and there's dog poop like everything is
in that cake everything so that's not
gonna hurt Trump but it could hurt
incumbent senators in purple states this
is what I was talking about yesterday if
you're worried about anything beyond
Trump and you should be because the
Republicans are vulnerable in the Senate
they have a very slim majority in the
Senate if Trump is reelected and he
doesn't have the Senate and he doesn't
have the house nothing is getting done
if Trump is not reelected and the
Republicans lose the Senate and the
Republicans don't retake the house then
you have a world of hurt you got
President Bernie Sanders with a
congressional majority I mean god bless
me I mean that that would just be the
worst of all available world so that
means that the prudent move here is to
hedge your bets to the extent that you
can and that would presumably mean
allowing a couple of witnesses to be
called including hunter Biden who would
in fact be damaging to Joe Biden and
then you move on because Trump is not
getting impeached or removed at least
over any of this Senator Tom Tillis of
North Carolina angrily tonight reports
that he told fellow Republicans on
Tuesday night that extending Trump's
trial would hurt vulnerable GOP
incumbents he said whoever went out of
that meeting and whoever informed the
press was either misled lying or an
imbecile I didn't say that I've been
very firm on this I have no problem
whatsoever with voting no on witnesses
for Republicans including Murkowski
having expressed interest in possibly
hearing from witnesses retiring senator
Lamar Alexander of Tennessee said he
intended to make up his mind after we've
heard the questions and the answers to
the questions on Thursday Mitt Romney of
course has been the clearest in saying
that he is interested in hearing from
some of the witnesses now the the the
Trump
is basically saying it's trying to make
a split case and I'm not sure it's a
great case on the one hand they're
saying that we don't need to hear from
witnesses on the other hand they are
saying that the Democrats don't have
enough information because they didn't
hear from witnesses that's kind of a
weird take right what you want to say is
the Democrats came with all they could
they didn't call witnesses because they
knew there is not gonna be anything
there and why would we call more
witnesses when the Democrats say that
they present a complete case right
instead the Republicans are making a
slightly different case which is less
well articulated and that case is that
the Democrats didn't do their job if
they had done their job and heard from
witnesses then we wouldn't have to do
this whole shebang at all but the
implication is that the Democrats
failure was not that they did a complete
report and just didn't end up with the
goods their failure was that they didn't
even do a complete report which sort of
suggests that okay well now you could do
a complete report right I mean could
have more witnesses Patrick Philbin
who's one of the lawyers for president
Trump said as much yesterday in in the
closing arguments that basically
yesterday was a day when the impeachment
managers for the house I'd be the
Democrats like Schiff and the Trump team
that would be Patrick Philbin and Alan
Dershowitz or asked questions via the
Chief Justice by the Senators the
senator submitted written questions to
the Chief Justice by the way can I just
say we should always do this like every
congressional hearing should be this
there should be just one person who's
delegated to ask the questions because
otherwise you end up with this insane
grandstanding I will say the process
yesterday was so much better just
because you had senators who couldn't
stand there and grandstand for five
minutes before getting to a question
mark I do a lot of Q&A is publicly
there's nothing more irritating than
when someone takes the mic tells you
their life story and never hits a
question mark well they didn't do that
yesterday and at least the process was a
little more anyway Patrick Philbin made
the case yesterday that no one goes to
trial without hearing from the witnesses
first why didn't the Democrats call the
witnesses if it was so all-fired
important again it's the argument is not
fantastic there's a better way to
articulate it but that's the argument
anyway the house managers try to present
it as if it so it's just a simple
question how can you have a trial
without witnesses but in real litigation
no one goes to trial without doing
discovery no one goes to trial with
having heard from the witnesses first
you don't show up at trial and then
start trying to call witnesses for the
first time and the implications here in
our constitutional structure for trying
to run things in such a an upside-down
way would be very grave for this body as
an institution okay let that it's bad
for the Senate's call witnesses is not a
very good argument the argument you
should be making me as Democrats say
that they had a complete case and their
case just is insufficient so we agree
with them this is their complete case
their complete case is insufficient that
is the best possible case for not having
witnesses we're gonna get two more on
the witnesses in just one second then
we'll get to a in an attack on Alan
Dershowitz that is utterly utterly
unearned I mean truly unearned people
deliberately taking Alan Dershowitz out
of context to pretend they don't
understand what he's talking about well
get to all of that in just one second
first let's talk about that time that
your car battery died so I remember one
time my car battery died and for some
odd reason I went over to the generic
auto body parts store and they did not
have the right battery I know weird
right didn't have the correct battery
and so I had to go to a second auto
parts store the whole day I don't have a
car because of all of this you know it
would have been a lot easier just going
to Rock Auto calm and getting the exact
part I need it and I'm looking I'm not a
car expert if I work our experts I'd be
looking at Rock Auto like every day
they've got all the parts and all the
all the specialized parts that you're
never gonna find at a generic auto auto
parts store Rock auto calm is a family
business serving auto parts customers
online for 20 years go to rockauto.com
to shop for auto and body parts from
hundreds of manufacturers they've got
everything from engine control modules
and brake parts to tail lamps motor oil
even new carpet whether it's for your
classic your daily driver get everything
you need in a few easy clicks deliver
directly to your door you don't have to
experience the store markup you don't
have to wait in line enough to get the
generic part as opposed to the
specialized part that you actually need
best of all prices at Rock Auto calm are
always reliably low and the same for
professionals and do-it-yourselfers
they've got great selection reliably low
prices all the parts your car will ever
need over at Rock Auto calm go to
rockauto.com right now see all the parts
available for your car or truck right
shapiro in there how did you hear about
us box so they know that we sent you
again that is rockauto.com
and make sure you write shapiro in there
how did you hear about us box so they
know we say you helps them helps us go
check them out rockauto.com make your
life easier when you're looking for auto
parts okay so Rudy Guiliani meanwhile
out there slamming John Bolton and this
again is bad strategy the the best
strategy with regards we don't want to
hear from John Bolton is he has nothing
new to say and even if what he says it's
true it doesn't make any difference
right that's the best strategy for not
calling the witness if your case is the
witness is a damn liar and everything
that the witness says is a lie and
violates national security well then the
question is why don't you call them as a
witness and then just cross-examine him
all right this is this is bad legal
tactics but Rudy Giuliani is he used to
be a good prosecutor it's been a while
since here's a prosecutor say here is
Rudy Giuliani going after john bolton
with a hatchet the only conclusion I can
come to and it's a harsh one and I feel
very bad about it he's a backstabber he
never said to me I've got a problem with
what you are doing in Ukraine never once
never winked never sent me a little note
that's classic backstabber so I feel I
got a swamp character here I find his
testimony about the president pretty
close to incredible close to incredible
okay so now he's calling a liar and a
backstabber but don't call them as a
witness guys don't call them as witness
that's a very hard case to make now
people on the on the right are trotting
out I'm trying to be as fair minded as I
can about this and I've said a thousand
times I don't think Trump did anything
impeachable here bad but not impeachable
is been my standard since the very
beginning where I don't think that he
did something great here but I also
don't think he did anything impeachable
here okay but people on the right are
trying to trot out this whole clip of
john bolton talking about president
Trump's calls with with vladimir
zalenski who's the president of ukraine
and they're trying to show that they're
saying well if john bolton hadn't had a
problem with this why didn't he say so
at the time i mean he did an interview
where he talked about trump's calls with
zalenski and the answer is yes you say
something different publicly about the
company who worked for then you say
privately behind the scenes to your boss
I mean like well these things are not
mutually exclusive
are we really going to treat it as
though everything everyone says publicly
about the place where they work
he's a reflection of what they're
actually saying inside the house I mean
that's that's silliness anyway here's
that clip of Bolton the people are
trotting out is the proof positive the
Bolton's now line I will be meeting
president zelanski he and President
Trump have already spoken twice
president called to congratulate
president Solinsky on his election and
then on his success in the parliamentary
election they were very warm and cordial
calls
hoping that they'll be able to meet in
Warsaw and have a few minutes together
okay so that that last line right there
we're hoping they're going to be able to
meet in Warsaw that can easily be read
as John Bolton trying to Telegraph to
the president and meet with him in
Warsaw right because this is what people
in the Trump administration do they go
on TV specifically in order to get
president Trump to pay attention to them
this is not a joke this is a thing that
happens on a regular basis in this White
House if you want the president to take
you seriously you go on TV he watches
you on TV and he takes you more
seriously this is well known and all of
the halls of power in Washington DC is
not me spilling the beans it's just a
reality okay so people trotting that out
and then Mark Meadows who can I like
congressman meadows from from North
Carolina you saying two GOP senators
Americans are paying attention to your
vote so you should be very careful how
you vote on the other prospects more
witnesses I mean I think that's true but
I don't think that Americans who are in
red states particularly care about this
I mean when I say they don't care I mean
they don't want more witnesses but
Americans in purple states like mark
Meadows doesn't have to worry about his
district but Susan Collins certainly has
to worry about her seat in Maine here's
Mark Meadows this is the most
consequential vote that any senator will
take perhaps other than sending troops
into harm's way and so the American
people are going to be looking at this
and they're going to say well did you
vote with the president that I voted for
or against him and that's why it will
have repercussions it's nothing that
will happen here on Capitol Hill but it
really will be the voters because they
are paying attention to this one vote
they may have tuned out on the hearings
they may not be viewing but they are
tuning in to how their senator is going
to vote on this particular issue I mean
that's true and again that's okay for
some of the Senators in real red states
it's it's more of a problem for some of
the senators who are not in those days
okay so some of the people who have come
under serious fire from the right side
of the aisle are people like Mitt Romney
so Romney submitted a series of
questions yesterday then were answered
on the floor of the Senate by both the
White House Counsel and the house
managers on the Democratic side and for
all of the people who are ripping Romney
up and down the questions that he asked
yesterday are basically the correct
questions in this particular case so the
questions that Romney asked were these
one this is to the White House Counsel
even that Rudy Giuliani's May 10th 2019
letter to president zalenski asserted he
was acting with the knowledge and
consent of President Trump what did
President from specifically tasked
Giuliani to do in Ukraine okay this is
the
basic question of the case right was
Giuliani there to dig up dirt about
hunter and Joe Biden for prospects of
2020 or was he there to dig up stuff
about 2016 it is perfectly obvious he
was there to dig up stuff about 2016 he
was in Ukraine in 2018 before Joe Biden
had even announced that he was going to
be running for the presidency that
didn't happen until 2019 so it is pretty
obvious that that was not about hunter
and Joe Biden Giuliani's original deploy
to deployment to two Ukraine the second
question that Romney asked was if
evidence indicates President Trump had
multiple purposes some in the national
interest some political for holding up
the security assistance is it the house
manager's position that the presence of
any political purpose should be grounds
for removing a president for abuse of
power okay now this is the this is the
big question right and it's the question
I've been asking since the very start
right I've offered two different
theories one was the Trump was planning
to go after Joe Biden theory and one is
the miasma of corruption theory the
miasma of corruption theory is that
Trump was concerned about some
legitimate things and also if it
happened to not Joe Biden well whatever
right that was the miasma of corruption
thing that was he was concerned about
2016 he was concerned about everything
from CrowdStrike to to Ukrainian
corruption to American funding of
Ukraine he was concerned about
everything from Purisima to the to the
record of Ukraine and fighting
corruption overall because he mentions
all of these things right every single
one of those things gets mentioned in
that phone call with zalenski the
transcripts of which is now public right
are they at least the the memo of which
is now public so the question being
asked is let's say that a president has
dual purposes I've been saying it like
good for Ramin except this has been the
question I've been asking all along
every day
literally every day for months let's say
the president has dual purposes one is
he wants to be more stingy with regard
to Ukrainian aid because he doesn't like
foreign aid generally and he's worried
about corruption and the second is that
is going to help his reelection
prospects if he with holds the foreign
aid and somehow gets investigations
started against a bunch of Democrats but
it's legit to get those investigations
started because it's also in America's
interest to find out what happened in
2016 and whether there was indeed
anything corrupt going on right let's
say that there's a dual purpose to
what's going on
is that enough to impeach and the answer
of course is no that's not enough to
impeach because the problem is that then
creates the principle that literally
anything a president does is impeachable
because there is not a
and who has ever lived who is not
looking with one eye toward reelection
in their first term not one everything
Barack Obama did in his first term was
at best directed toward two purposes one
what he thought was in the national
interest and two every election because
your politician that what politicians do
are we just gonna pretend that
politicians are truly altruistic public
servants who never have an eye on
re-election at all of course everything
they do is designated for a couple of
purposes it's only corruption when you
cut against the national interest
deliberately for your own private
purposes right then you have something
that's impeachable something that's
removable right when you are talking
about something where it's a
dual-purpose thing right where it serves
both your political interest and also
what you believe to be the national
interest of the country and it's not
just that you believe it to be the
national interest of the country but
there can be a fair haze made that the
American people should believe it to be
in the national interest of the country
then that obviously is not impeachable
right that's the question that Mitt
Romney is asking and this is where the
left is going after Alan Dershowitz
today yeah the left is going after
Dershowitz Dershowitz is of course the
acting is attorney for Trump in this
case we'll get to the attacks on
Dershowitz in just a moment first let us
talk about a fantastic thing that you
can do for yourself and your family this
year I'm talking about something I'm
doing myself that is use a legacy box
and what is legacy box well you go out
to your garage got a bunch of old films
film reels out there do you still have
one of those old cameras that projects
on the wall if the answer is no if you
haven't had one of those for 60 years
but you got those old film reels out in
the in the garage and they're just
moldering well why not take those and
put them in a digital format and now you
can see all the tapes from when grandma
was young or when mom and dad were young
when you were young why not do all that
it's just fantastic and make it easier
to schlep that stuff around so you got
boxes that stuff in the garage instead
and I can get it on a thumb drive or a
DVD or a digital download
that's what legacy box does you take all
of your stuff you just dump it in a box
for legacy box you put some labels on it
so that you can track each piece of
memorabilia you are sending them they
then digitize all of that and they send
you back the digital and they send you
as well your original stuff they are
great at this they've been doing it for
years tens of thousands of clients they
really are fantastic get started
preserving your past today go to legacy
box comm slash pen and get 40% off your
first order
save your time and memories go to legacy
box comm /ban and you can save 40% right
now which is a great price and it's a
grip makes a great gift for mom and dad
particularly but it's also
great for you go check out legacy box
comments not just the film rails by the
way if you got old VHS right who has a
VCR anymore I mean my kids don't even
know what a VCR is hey go check it out
right now legacy box comm slash Ben save
at 40% okay so Alan Dershowitz comes
under fire specifically because he seeks
to answer the question that MIT Romney
is asking which is if the evidence
indicates that Trump had multiple
purposes some in the national interests
some political for holding up security
assistance is it the house managers
position that the presence of any
political purpose should be grounds for
removing a president for abuse of power
music here's Alan Dershowitz suggesting
that activity that helps the president
and helps the country is fine now the
media are reading this as though
Dershowitz is saying that any action you
take in your own reelected interest is
fine then of course it's not what
they're shorts is saying because that
would be an idiotic case you'd have to
be like a complete dunderhead to believe
that like because that basically says
okay if the president goes and just
kills joe biden but he believes that
it's in his own electoral interest to do
so
well then that's okay it's at least not
impeachable and of course nobody
believes that it would be saying that
that Nixon's crimes during Watergate
would've been fine because after all it
was own is in his own real active
interest first Woods isn't making that
case sir Schwartz is saying something
that is perfectly obvious and everybody
in the media is pretending they don't
understand it because everybody in the
media is corrupt or at least a huge
number of people in the media are
corrupt well get to the media a little
bit later on in the program because they
truly are awful but what Dershowitz is
is trying to say here fairly obviously
since he has said it on this program is
that if a president both has a public
purpose for what he's doing and also has
an eye toward reelection that is not
impeachable because if it were
impeachable and presidents would never
be able to do anything so here is
Dershowitz and what he actually had to
say yesterday every public official that
I know believes that his election is in
the public interest and mostly you're
right your election is in the public
interest and if a president does
something which he believes will help
him get elected in the public interest
that cannot be the kind of quid pro quo
that results in impeachment okay so the
way that people are reading that is that
Dershowitz is saying that if you do
something that is only in your own
reelected interest because you believe
that you're better a candidate and so
you can do what you want that would be
an
abroad in ridiculous argument obviously
that'd be an insane argument would be
patently crazy okay but what Dershowitz
is actually saying I believe strongly
since he has said this before is that if
you do something that you believe is in
the national interest and it is in your
reelected interest then the fact that it
is also in your real active interest
does not make it impeach able because
everybody has their eye toward
re-election right that like clearly and
obviously okay now the Democrats
immediately jump on this they're saying
well now Trump is making a full-on
dictatorial argument and by the way it
would be true right if merciless were
actually saying that yours wish to be
reelected allows you to do anything in
pursuit of reelection yes that would be
a dictatorial argument that's not what
thirst Woods is actually say ok so Adam
Schiff goes on national TV says this
gives us carte blanche to cheat right
this is giving Trump carte blanche to
cheat because he could then just go do
whatever he wants in pursuit of his own
reelection all quid pro quos are fine
it's carte blanche is that really what
we're prepared to say with respect to
this president's conduct or the next
because if we are then the next person
itíd states can ask for an investigation
of you they can ask for help in their
next election from any foreign power and
the art will be made no Donald Trump was
acquitted for doing exactly the same
thing therefore it must not be
impeachable okay now shift steps right
in it here the reason he steps right and
he says the next president can do
anything the next president could like
you know for example just you know use a
foreign source to initiate an
investigation against a political
opponent and if they thought it was in
the reelect of interest it would be it'd
be totally it would be totally okay
under the standard currently articulated
so Jay Sekulow who's the counsel for the
White House gets up and says I'm like
have you not been watching for the past
several years when the Obama FBI and DOJ
initiated an investigation into Donald
Trump based on trumped up garbage from
the Russians like were you not aware of
that the Department of Justice and the
FBI engaged in an investigation of the
candidate for president in the United
States when they started their operation
called crossfire hurricane he said it
would be targeting a rival well that's
what that did he said it would be
calling for foreign assistance
that this was in 2016 against a rival
campaign so we don't have to do
hypotheticals that's precisely the
situation he left went nuts over this
but of course what seculow is saying is
essentially true when people say well it
wasn't an investigation into Trump
personally well it kind of was okay
let's be real about this it was
initiated as an investigation into
Carter page and it quickly became an
investigation into the entire Trump
campaign which is why the Trump campaign
was not notified that Carter page was
being investigated and Paul Manafort was
being investigated until much much later
I guess anyway the Democrats decide that
they are going to move with this with
this basic notion that Alan Dershowitz
is a dictator right civil libertarian
Alan Dershowitz is an actual dictator
who wants the president to be able to
get off scot-free for anything he does
so long as he can claim that it's in his
reelected interest Gloria Borger on CNN
which is well under this standard
couldn't you arrest your political
opponents I mean the answer is yes but
that's not Durst what's a standard maybe
he was trying to appeal to narcissism of
politicians I have absolutely no idea
what he was trying to do but he
effectively said if you believe you
should be President
then you can do anything you want to
make yourself president because you will
believe that is in the national interest
so my question would be can you arrest
an opponent of yours I mean you know the
story you can ask questions like that ad
infinitum it is a ridiculous argument
I'm not a lawyer so ok stipulate that
stipulate that well I mean why don't we
stipulate that everybody is deliberately
misunderstanding what Dershowitz is
saying because you have to assume a
baseline level of intelligence on door
shorts apart he's not an idiot
nobody is going to make the actual overt
case that the president can do anything
he wants on behalf of his own reelection
that's ridiculous but of course this is
what the media run with because they're
trying to portray Trump as a dictator so
trying to suggest that Alan Dershowitz
is stumping in fact on behalf of
dictatorship is a pretty rich vein to
mine Joe Lockhart on CNN doing the same
thing suggesting this is Hitler again
it's Mussolini it's like Italy go Joe
Lockhart go having worked in about a
dozen campaigns there is always the
sense that boy if we win it's better for
the country but that doesn't give you
license to commit crimes or to do things
that
unethical so it was absurd and what I
thought when I was watching it was this
is unamerican
this is what you hear from Stalin this
is what you hear from Mussolini would
you hear from authority from Hitler from
all the authoritarian people who
rationalized a you know in some cases
genocide based on what was in the public
interest okay so if you think that this
is that this is truly just about what if
you think that they're interpreting
Dershowitz correctly then I ask what
their Schwartz is talking about in the
next clip
okay so Dershowitz then asks he would go
on to ask was it impeachment what Obama
didn't bomb Syria because he believed it
would help his that it would it would
hurt his electoral chances the point
being that foreign policy is quite
malleable and that if you do something
that you believe is in the national
interest and it includes your reelection
interest then that's answerable that's
okay right here is Alan Dershowitz left
wing of your party is really gonna give
you a hard time if you start selling
lethal weapons and getting into a lethal
war potentially with Russia would
anybody here suggest that was
impeachable well let's assume President
Obama said I promise to bomb Syria if
they had chemical weapons but I'm now
told by my pollsters that bombing Syria
would hurt my electoral chances
certainly not impeachable at all I mean
the point that he's making is that if
it's not a crime in the essence of it
right if the president has plenty of
discretion in a particular area and
politics plays into the describe the use
of the discretion that's not impeachable
he's making the argument I'm making
right if you do something and you
believe that it could go either way it's
in the national interest and the
national interest could go either way
and also you have an eye toward
reelection that's not impeachable and
that of course is true
okay now the left has also been going
nuts over Patrick Philbin one of the
president's attorneys yesterday making
the perfectly obvious point that it is
not a campaign finance violations to
accept information from foreign source
now I've talked at length about this
before Eugene over at UCLA
school of real awe wrote a long piece
about this probably now three to four
years ago regarding the use of
information from a foreign source in a
campaign and points it out this is not a
campaign finance violation because that
is not a quote unquote thing of value
under campaign finance law but when the
president's lawyer says this is
apparently a big
apparently mere information is not
something that would violate the
campaign finance laws and if there is
credible information credible
information of wrongdoing by someone who
is running for a public office it's not
campaign interference for credible
information about wrongdoing to be
brought to light if it's credible
information so I think that the idea
that any information that happens to
come from overseas is necessarily
campaign interference is is a mistake
okay
and and what he's saying there is again
uncontroversial but it was played as
controversial today because everything
was played as controversial there was a
study out today showing that 100 percent
of the media coverage of Team Trump in
this has been negative not 99 percent
100 percent of the media coverage from
the mainstream media non Fox News has
been negative 95 percent has been
positive for Democrats which is not any
shock at all even though the Democrats
have been fibbing throughout this
process so Adam Schiff yesterday he did
a couple of things where he just overtly
lied someone he characterized Trump's
conversation with zalenski and he he
again lied about what Trump said he did
this before and he made up his whole
like I'm a mafioso conversation with
Trump you remember this he did a whole
spiel in the house where he suggested
that Trump had gotten on the line and
said I want you to do me a favor go out
there and do that line and I won't break
down your house right that whole thing
well he did the same thing yesterday
again because he actually changed the
language if you read the Zielinski call
Trump says we'd like you to do us a
favor meaning he believes it's in the
national interest right and then Schiff
said no no it's do me a favor okay well
no if you change the language from to us
to do me a favor that's actually a
distinction with a difference it makes a
difference okay then shift claims
yesterday that he hasn't had that his
staff has had no contact with the
whistleblower which of course is an
overt lie I mean the fact is that his
staff coordinated with the whistleblower
we already have testimony to that effect
first of all I don't know who the
whistleblower is I haven't met them or
communicated with them in any way the
community the committee staff did not
write the complaint or coach the
whistleblower what to put in the
complaint the committee staff did not
see the complaint before it was
submitted to the Inspector General the
committee including its staff did not
receive the complaint
until the night before Acting Director
of National Intelligence we had an open
hearing with the active director on
September 26 more than three weeks after
the legal deadline by which the
committee should have received the
complaint okay just gonna point out that
his staff overtly coordinated with
whistleblower like we know that that is
not a speculation that is a fact or they
do we know that because shift staff has
actually said as much right chief has
said that his own staff coordinated with
the whistleblower so that of course is
absolute inherent nonsense I mean it's
just absolutely silly towns meanwhile
the Democrats who are desperate for
witnesses they're desperate for
witnesses except for hunter Biden of
course I came jeffrey says there's no
reason we should ever call hunter biden
why should we have hunter Biden hunter
Biden's not relevant here even though he
is at the center of the entire thing
right
if Trump never asked about hunter Biden
we would not be talking about any of
this would we really if he'd been asking
about CrowdStrike if you've been asking
about all of the crazy conspiracy
theories he was asking about in Ukraine
but he never mentioned hunter Biden we
wouldn't be talking about any of this so
yes hunter Biden is relevant because it
matters whether or not hunter Biden did
something corrupt it prompted the the
question in the first place
what's my view that hunter Biden is not
a relevant witness but I have great
respect for Joe Manchin and for all of
the senators on both sides of the aisle
and ultimately they in the first
instance will make this decision in
terms of the witnesses that should be
called although none of the mention
indicated I do believe that Chief
Justice John Roberts should be the
ultimate arbiter and referee in terms of
deciding relevant so now the Democrats
are trying to kick it over to Roberts
they can blame Roberts a Bush appointee
obviously if it turns out that he that
that he allows hunter Biden to be
brought in testimony meanwhile the
Democrats are trying to claim with
regard to hunter Biden that unless
Donald Trump asked about hunter Biden
and burries m'a before Biden announced
his investigation then it would be then
he's only doing this for his reelection
prospects okay first of all that take
sort of ignores the timeline which is
the Rudy Giuliani was wandering around
Ukraine in the middle of 2018 according
to a whistle-blower report right I mean
so like he was wandering around there
gathering information on Purisima
apparently in 2018 so first of all
that's pretty obvious
second of all even if Donald Trump only
asked about hunter Biden once it became
that clear that that Joe was actually
running for president that again does
not mean that's directed toward 2020
it means that maybe it's a little bit
more relevant whether the the guy who
just declared for president was engaged
in corruption in 2016 than it was five
minutes ago right it does elevate and
nobody was asking about the trunk about
Donald Trump's associations with Russia
until he declared who's running for the
presidency so is it then illegitimate
for the DOJ to look into him because he
had declared that he was running for the
presidency it's a very weird take Alan
Dershowitz deconstructed that one
yesterday on the floor let's assume
hypothetically that the president was in
a second term and he said to himself you
know Joe Biden's running for president I
really should now get concerned about
whether his son is corrupt because he's
not only a candidate and he's not
running against me I'm finished with my
term but he could be the President of
the United States and if he's the
President of the United States and he
has a corrupt son the fact that he's
announced his candidacy is a very good
reason for upping the interest in his
son if he wasn't running for president
he's a husband he's the former vice
president United States okay big deal
but if he's running for president
that's an enormous big deal okay so as
we move forward
people are asking like okay so it's
perfectly obvious to everybody in the
media that they are right and everybody
else is wrong where you got down lemon
on TV laughing at all the hick rube
Trump supporters and all the rest of
this and then they wonder why is it that
so many Americans are just ignoring the
media's take on this and the answer is
because as always this is not really
about Republican versus Democrat this is
about Trump versus the media as always
everything boils down to Trump versus
the media because the filter you are
seeing things through unless you are
sitting there and actually watching the
wall-to-wall testimony in this case
which nobody has done I haven't even
done it right I've been watching it
pretty steadily but even I have not done
it then the filter that you are hearing
is the filter of the media and most
people just don't trust the media on
either side we're gonna get to that in
just one second first quick note if you
know anything about the show you know
that we are dramatically pro-life you
may also remember that last year I did
my podcast live from the March for Life
in Washington DC
I spoke to tens of thousands of people
about the pro-life cause well you may
not know is that we then received
blowback from all of the jackasses over
on the wild left-wing more interested in
canceled culture they went after some of
our advertisers we did lose some revenue
and this is why we asked you to
subscribe at daily wire but we have
better news than that if you subscribe
right now it's a live wire we will give
a portion
of your subscription when you use promo
code live-action to my friends over at
live-action there an actual pro-life
group there an educational group and
they spend their days trying to push the
messages of life and the messages of
protection of the unborn to the American
public and the public abroad use promo
code live-action right now and when you
subscribe from now until January 31st
you got to do it like right now does
this ends tomorrow a portion of any
daily where com membership will be
donated to my friends over at
live-action with promo code live-action
Lila Rose runs that place it is
fantastic I personally give money to
live-action there's only a few days left
meaning like today and tomorrow so join
daily we're calm make your pro life a
voice heard before it is too late you
are listening to the largest
fastest-growing conservative podcast and
radio show in the nation
[Music]
okay so the the breakdown on impeachment
is puzzling to the media they don't
understand why after 100% negative media
coverage the American public is still
split 50-50 and the answer to that is
because nobody trusts the media I know
there's a constant refrain from the
right and I know that the left believes
that this is because of Trump it is not
because of Trump the media had lost all
credibility before Trump came on the
scene there
you don't remember back in 20 it would
been 2012 when Newt Gingrich was running
for president and Newt Gingrich bashed
the moderator but who's John Harwood in
one of the debate exchanges and
immediately soared to the top of the
Republican polls if people have hated
the mainstream media for decades in the
Republican Party they do so with a
reason and the mainstream media prove
everyday why we shouldn't trust them
when it comes to analysis of ongoing
issues perfect example so you remember
that just a couple of days ago Don Lemon
went on air and was laughing
hysterically as was a hot Ally and Rick
Wilson made nasty jokes about Trump
supporters suggesting that they were
toothless rube Hicks who didn't know how
to read a map well then Don Lemon went
on TV last night to apologize it and
simply forgot the part where he was
going to apologize and one final note
that I have for you because this is
personally important to me to address
this okay anyone ask anyone who knows me
they'll tell you I don't believe in
belittling people belittling anyone for
who they are what they believe or where
they're from during an interview on
Saturday night one of my guests said
something that made me laugh and while
in the moment I found that joke humorous
and I didn't catch everything that was
said just to make this perfectly clear I
was laughing at the joke and not at any
group of people okay but what but the
joke was about a group of people so
you're gonna have to explain that one
and don't worry no apology necessary by
the way I I do find it funny Don Lemon
just owned it right though the fact that
Don Lemon clings to this ridiculous
notion that he is some sort of objective
journalist is it's it's absolutely
telling us it's it's funny I remember I
was covering the RNC back in 2012 and
one of the and one of the sort of
big-name reporters from the 1980s was
was walking around in the Sam Donaldson
Sam Donaldson
remember because of the eyebrows and Sam
Donaldson was walking around at the at
the RNC in Tampa in beautiful Tampa and
we and I came across him and I started
asking him at the time he was hosting a
political show for I believe it was ABC
News and I asked him so your overtly
political now and he said yes and I said
and you're overtly a Democrat now he
said yes and I said well were you all
did you always hold these political
views and he said yes and I said so why
didn't you just say that for 30 years
and he got very agitated he got very
agitated and he got right up in my face
and he said are you saying that you're
better than I am when I said well yeah I
kind of am I mean because I like I just
say that I'm a conservative and I don't
lie about it like I just I will tell you
exactly that I don't pretend for 30
years that I am objective voice of truth
and then go on the air and spout exactly
the same kind of crap I do when I'm an
opinion oast this is the problem for
places like CNN and also the
self-centeredness of the media the
self-centeredness is truly astonishing
there's a great and by gramming
ridiculous piece in the new york times
today by a guy named Charlie Waddell
he's an opinion writer at-large for the
New York Times it's called what will you
do when the culture war comes for you
newsrooms still aren't ready for the
trolls and this is all about how sad it
is to be a reporter
the culture war will come for us all on
Sunday came from Washington Post
reporter Felicia's on meds nine people
were killed in a helicopter crash in
Calabasas California that morning
including the basketball legend Kobe
Bryant and his 13 year old daughter
Gianna the news rocketed around social
media where mourners shared their
heartbreak at the news as is common with
major breaking news some reports were
inaccurate or false layering in his ID
on top of grief into the mix Masson has
tweeted the link to a 2016 article from
The Daily Beast about a young woman's
accusation that mr. Bryant had raped her
in Colorado criminal charges against him
were dropped in 2004 and a civil suit
was settled out of court
the tweet highlighted the fact that mr.
Bryant's legacy is fraught and
complicated and attracted the attention
of fans as well as trolls who barn
Potter who bombarded her inbox with
abuse and posted her home address online
all of which is completely unjustified
Masson has then posted a selection of
the threats she received without
obscuring the names of people who had
sent her hate mail she slept in a hotel
on Sunday night fearing for her safety
at home we don't know all the details
but it seems that the post managing and
executive editors were not pleased
they chastised her over the email they
placed her on administrative leave while
the organization reviewed whether she
had violated the company's social media
guidelines the reasoning on Monday was
the tweets display
poor judgment that undermined the work
of her colleagues that post then
reversed her suspension on Tuesday
roughly 36 hours after the initial
tweets stating that senior managers had
concluded that Mossad mezes tweets
didn't violate company policy this of
course was obvious to almost everyone
but the post higher-ups it was
impossible to imagine how posting a link
to a story by a different publication on
Twitter could undermine the work of
colleagues just as it was impossible to
imagine which colleagues would have felt
undermined there remains a glaring
question to the executive editor Marty
Baron inquire about miss on message
safety when he emailed her to criticize
her tweets what beyond her reflux for
online civility led the post to
determine the reporter was hurting this
institution by discussing a part of mr.
Bryan's legacy that appeared in the post
own news pages okay so here's the thing
this article is right that the
Washington Post should not have
suspended this journalist they shouldn't
have the canceled culture is stupid it
is idiotic
okay the fact that people didn't like
what this person tweeted does not mean
that you should have been removed from
her job at the Washington Post for ìlet
for tweeting in I would say at least
ill-timed fashion an article about Kobe
Bryant's rape case from 2004 okay but
the lack of the utter lack of
understanding that what the media do
every day is cancel culture is
astonishing so it's only bad when it
hits a reporter but let's just be real
about this the New York Times has come
for the Covington Catholic kids the New
York Times has come for shows like mine
the folks over at Media Matters who are
who are in cahoots with the mainstream
media they have a can their own little
kind of retweet circle where they tried
to gin up outrage at particular outrages
of the day and janab outrage and
advertisers they've been doing this for
years and only when it hits the media to
the media suddenly get upset about it
they don't care when it's a normal
citizen they don't care when they're
digging up all the crap on Joe the
Plumber from 2008 then that's perfect
that's us journalism it guys but if you
guys object to any of our journalists
saying X Y or Z and then you email the
editors at our newspaper then that's
canceled culture and it's very very bad
the utter blind spot that the media have
to their own incompetence and sin to
what they do every day is truly amazing
and truly horrifying and it's one of the
reasons why the American people do not
believe that the media is stand for them
they don't believe that the media stand
for the truth they believe that the
media stand for the media and the media
are in it for the glory that the media
are in it for the clicks and that the
media are in it for the money when the
media do not have a consistent standard
when it comes to even things like
canceled culture I have a pretty
consistent
and I defended people right left and
center who have been subjected to
canceled culture I think it's garbage
but people on the Left they don't have
this standard and people in the media
don't have this standard and the sort of
self pitying attitude with regard to the
media all over is just it's off-putting
in the extreme and the whole take that
you've gotten from the media during the
Trump era for years that Trump is
uniquely brutal to the media Barack
Obama arrested journalists okay he
wiretap journalists James Rosen was
wiretap the AP was wiretapped okay the
the the notion that journalists have an
extremely rough because Mike Pompeo had
a mean thing to a journalist from NPR is
just absurd it's just ridiculous the
back-and-forth between journalists and
their subjects has been anything for
quite a long time if he can't take the
heat get out of the kitchen and yet the
New York Times prints another piece from
mary-louise Kelly the co-host of NPR's
all things considered because Mike
Pompeo was a meanie to her very very
mean she rides ask journalists why they
do the job they do and you'll hear a
range of answers here's mine not every
day but on the best ones we get to put
questions to powerful people and hold
them to account this is both a privilege
and responsibility I would love just one
question from NPR to Bernie Sanders
about whether he believes private
property is right the reason we don't
trust you guys is when you say you put
questions to powerful people and hold
them to account
you only mean one side of the aisle and
only when it benefits you politically so
no you don't get any sort of special
exemption in the rough and tumble of
American politics by the way Mike Pompeo
put out his own comment with regard to
his tete-a-tete with Mary with with Mary
Louise Kelly because it turns out that
that she approached
Pompeo and Pompeyo got mad at her and
Pompeyo suggested that she didn't know
where Ukraine was on a map the
irrelevant portion of the interview was
Kelly said how do you stop Iran from
getting a nuclear weapon and pumphouse
said we'll stop them and she said how
sanctions he said we'll stop them okay
and then she talked about how the how
the Iranians were blustering and then he
apparently called her a liar during
another exchange and challenged her to
find Ukraine on an unmarked map and this
was apparently very very bad very very
bad and very very mean Pompeyo says that
Kelly first lied in setting up our
interview he says I agreed to come on
your show today to talk about Iran and
then she said no no you came on to talk
about Ukraine and then
he shouted at her a little bit and this
is very mean and very bad and how dare
anybody do any sort of thing
okay so Pompeo released a statement I
said look go back and take a look
there's a lot of history with NPR and
Mike Pompeo and Iran it goes back to
2015 2015
where NPR lied they took money from
plowshares and we're part of the Ben
Rhodes echo chamber and they ultimately
had to go on air and say yep it's true
we took money from plowshares and didn't
disclose it after enormous pressure from
congressman Pompeo there's a lot of
history there so I took a leap of faith
with Mary Louise invited her to the
State Department back in December we had
a great conversation she asked me if I'd
do her the favor of granting her an
interview I said sure there's a lot of
history to fix let's talk about Iran she
agreed that we would talk about Iran and
we set up an interview I hope she finds
peace okay but here's the bottom line
whatever the kind of details of this
silly dust-up the fact that members of
the media are writing in other media
outlets about how victimized they are as
members of the media because it's so
rough for them it's the reason why the
credibility of the media has been in the
toilet for years at this point and Trump
has been able to take advantage of that
so you guys would you like to restore
your credibility you could do something
very simple you could stop being awful
at your jobs you could stop being
completely thoroughgoing ly awful at
your jobs and if you're gonna be on the
Left just an answer on the left because
guess what
I don't criticize MSNBC for being biased
I've never done it on the air I don't
criticize them for being on the left
there are like I'll criticize what they
say I'll make fun of Chris Matthews all
right now as they say but I never go on
I'm like I can't believe the bias at
MSNBC they say who they are good I
criticize CNN I criticize NPR I
criticize the New York Times you guys
want your credibility back you're gonna
have to earn it in a second we're gonna
get two things I like and things that I
hate so let's do it let's do a thing I
like okay so the thing that I like so
I'm into watching stupid 1990s action
films with my wife at this point and it
is indeed a fun thing to do so because
there is a new bad boys movie that is
coming out there's a new bad boys movie
coming out and I haven't seen it yet
I've never even seen the original bad
boys but I will say that Michael Bay
because Michael Bay is Michael Bay and
he was the first person to be Michael
Bay and so many people ripped off
Michael Bay he has now become sort of an
unappreciated commodity the fact is he's
made some of his best films in the
recent past like 13 13 hours is actually
a very good film and the critics savaged
it because they don't like that Michael
Bay is probably a Republican he's
probably at least a little bit
right-wing so they don't like that
okay so Michael Bay his first movie was
bad boys
which of course has become this major
franchise now with Will Smith and Martin
Lawrence so I went back and watched with
my wife and it's delightfully stupid it
is it is truly a pleasure of idiocy and
it's exactly what you would think it is
right it is it is guns and cursing and
jokes and scantily clad women all the
things that have made America great
historically anyway here's a little bit
of the trailer for bad boys I did this
in preparation for taking my wives also
a huge Will Smith fan so here's a little
bit of the trailer for bad boys it's
still Michael Bay
it was foolproof
[Music]
[Applause]
there was the perfect crime
but the Miami detectives Marcus Burnett
and Mike Lowrey so it it's a very very
silly movie obviously and yet that is
the glory of it if you want to watch a
matter in Michael Bay movie the rock is
actually an actively good intensity
right that's that play it's got all the
Michael Bay silliness but perfected into
the heights of Michael Bay in any case
Michael Bay is like I kind of feel bad
because Michael Bay's new stuff is
actually better than his old stuff but
because he's Michael Bay he's been sort
of discounted anyway if you want to go
back to back in what like view my wife
and I we've been on this jag lately
because honestly my kids are wiping me
out you gotta watch them dumb at night
to kind of like bring you back a little
bit so check out bad boys looking for
something dumb to watch tonight it is
definitely rated R so if you're not up
for rated R movies then then it's not
for you okay time for a quick thing that
I hate okay so a couple of quick things
that I hate so number one this is an
absurd story so according to Jessica
contraire over at The Washington Post on
Friday President Trump is expected to
attend a White House summit organized by
his daughter Ivanka on human trafficking
an issue he frequently invokes his top
priority but some of the country's most
prominent anti trafficking organizations
and advocates won't be there they've
decided to boycott the event that group
includes Polaris the nonprofit
organization that runs the National
Human Trafficking hotline and the leader
of the freedom network USA the country's
largest anti-trafficking coalition their
decision comes after months of anguish
over what they described as an act of
public deception they say that although
the president frequently invokes human
trafficking his administration is
actively endangering a significant
portion of trafficking victims
immigrants so in other words they don't
like Trump's policies on illegal
immigration so they're not going to show
up to fight human trafficking from the
White House this is the height of
stupidity
it is incredibly dumb because these two
things actively do not have all that
much to do with each other in fact if
they do have something to do with each
other then the thing that should be
happening is you should explain how the
policy of the against illegal
immigration does not actually help stop
the coyotes who are engaged in human
trafficking across the border but
because everybody has connected the two
policies in their mind they're they're
boycotting the invitations
three of the groups told The Washington
Post they fear backlash over their
decision so they cited conflicts with
other events so that this is what
they're doing now therefore backlash
from their lefty base and even though if
uncle Trump is trying
work hard on human trafficking they are
not going to stand up to their lefty
base and on the other hand they fear
backlash from the right and so they're
citing conflict Trump repeatedly brings
up human trafficking when discussing
immigration policy in 2018 he became the
first sitting president to attend a
meeting of the federal trafficking task
force since its creation in 2000 a
banker Trump has advocated anti
trafficking legislation including a law
intended to strengthen prosecutors
ability to go after websites that host
advertisements for commercial sex she
wrote about these efforts and others in
a 2018 op-ed in The Washington in the
Washington Post but now people are
boycotting this because they don't like
Trump's immigration position which again
is just pretty wild stuff it's pretty
wild stuff but perfectly typical for
this moment in time okay one other thing
that I hate so yesterday I so yesterday
I did a long a long bit on the history
of the Middle East and there's a map
going around that is completely idiocy
it has no relation to reality so I
figure I was just a bunk this year
online machine Nawaz who is a Muslim
commentator in Britain actually debunked
this yesterday but I figured that I will
walk you through this since you've
probably seen this online so if you
can't see the map you should subscribe
so you can see things like this if you
can't see the map basically it shows
historic Palestine and then it shows the
entire thing Ingrid the entire State of
Israel in green then it shows 1947 UN
Partition Plan and the Arab areas in
green then it shows the 1967 borders the
pre-1967 borders right because after
1967 and Israel had control of the
entire Land of Israel as currently
constituted and they show that and then
they show these are the border lines
endorsed by the PLO in 1988 as his
historic a compromise for peace and then
it shows basically the pre-1967 borders
and then it shows at Trump's projected
plan and how much control it would
actually give to the to the Palestinians
in terms of the areas that they would
control okay so these maps are just a
mess they're a complete mess I'll
explain why they are a complete mess
moving from early to late first it shows
a map of quote-unquote historic
Palestine all green it was never Arab
territory ever hey it was a it was not
it was never an independent state there
was no historic Palestine state it did
not exist it was a territory of the
British Mandate at the time of the of
the Balfour Declaration before that it
was it was just a part of the Ottoman
Empire there never was
a quote-unquote independent historic
Palestine that was that was Arab owned
okay that is not a thing that has ever
happened so this map is just a fantasy
it doesn't exist okay and then and there
is no way to explain this map as saying
this was quote-unquote Arab populated
cuz there were Jews there too so this is
obviously not a population map the the
map is a complete fiction the idea is
that there was a legal status of an
independent Palestine that was Arabic
never has been the case in human history
okay next map so then they move forward
it's in the 1947 UN Partition Plan and
it does depict the 1947 UN partition
plan then it says 44 percent of historic
Palestine
okay this neglects the fact that the
original Balfour Declaration number one
included Jordan as part of the Jewish
state that was then sliced off and then
another 44 percent was sliced off for
another state for the Arabs and then
this also neglected to mention that you
know who rejected this plan you know
that they're acting as though this was
the plan that had been accepted than the
Israelis over an it
this plan would was accepted by the Jews
the Jews accepted this UN Partition Plan
you know who didn't accept this UN
Partition Plan the Arabs who then
launched the 1947 48 War of Independence
and proceeded to get their asses kicked
so that would be a them problem that
would be a your fault problem if you are
a member of an arab government and then
you decided to launch a war without
accepting a deal you don't get to whine
about the deal that was on the table
that you rejected okay that's a your
fault problem the entire refugee problem
with regard to the palestinians would
not exist if the Arabs had simply
accepted this deal that was on the table
that the Israelis did except by the way
you can see those borders are absolute
nonsense
right I mean those borders are insane
for for the the integrity of any Jewish
state completely crazy like no way to
make that workable basically Israel is
in three separate parts there it's
completely wild okay so they show that
map and this is supposed to show the
Palestinian territory shrunk it did not
shrink because it didn't exist before
and beyond that it didn't shrink because
they didn't accept it right it was
completely not accepted okay now to the
next map so they move forward to the
sixty to the pre sixty-seven borders
they say 1967 border lines endorsed by
PLO in 1988 as historic compromise for
peace okay a couple of things about this
one this is pre 67 war so and they say
1967 they mean pre-1967 really again
then the state 22% historic Palestine
first of all they owned all of this
territory the Arabs controlled all of
this territory prior to 1967 so what
happened in 1967 you you may be asking
yourself oh that's right
Jordan Egypt Syria and Saudi Arabia
launched another war of extermination
against the Jews and then they proceeded
to lose that territory so they had that
territory and then they lost that
territory
you're whining about the fact they lost
territory that you had and then you
launched an attack beyond that it is
just a lie that these border lines were
endorsed by the PLO in 1919 88 if this
had been endorsed by the PLO we'd
already have a peace deal it would
already be over right they were endorsed
as the starting point for negotiations
but they did not acknowledge that there
are already a lot of Jews living in that
area they didn't but you can see that
the map includes Jerusalem right in see
the map includes Jerusalem in the green
area okay that was never agreed to by
the Jews there was never any negotiation
in which Jews were going to either split
up or give up Jerusalem the holiest city
in Judaism not going to happen and a
city that had been split prior to 1967
and in which Jews were not allowed to
any of the holy sites and that was never
going to happen
beyond that the notion that this was the
border endorsed by the Palestinians is
complete and abject crap the reason it's
complete abject crap is because one of
their other demands is the so-called
right of return which would have swamped
the State of Israel with an additional
five million Palestinians as of now
which means they never accepted the
territorial deal see this is the great
lie they keep saying well it's arguments
over territory it is not arguments over
territory you know how we know it's not
argument over territory because you know
who offered this exact map with a few
land swaps if we Barak in 2008 who told
Merritt in 2008 you know the
Palestinians did when offered this map
with half of Jerusalem you know what
they did they walked away from the table
with how to counteroffer and launch a
wave of violence oh this map is crap too
so three of the four maps you've gone
through are now crap finally we get to
the Trump plan okay so they show the
Trump projected plan and here it shows
15% of historic Palestine and they show
the the green areas as the parts that
would be the Palestinian state okay well
now they've actually changed the metric
that they are using for explaining which
territory is held by the Palestinians
because before if you go back to the 67
map right if you go back to the 67 map
they are showing territory that is not
population based right they're just kind
of drawing a line you'll notice that the
next map the the Trump plan is
population based meaning these are the
areas that are actively controlled by
the Palestinians they weren't actively
controlled by the Palestinians post 67
even in 1988 right those none of those
here
is included any of the highways and
byways and the Jewish settlements that
were gonna be carved out so now they're
using a completely different metric
they're using the land that would
actually be controlled by the
Palestinians in a peace deal the 60 the
pre 67 borders that was never endorsed
by anybody and it was never going to be
the final the final status negotiations
so that map is going around it is
complete abject crap from beginning to
end people who doubt that number one
believe you're an ignoramus and so you
don't know what they're doing and number
two our propagandist because this is
perfect propaganda it is absolute
propaganda the goal of it is to show how
Palestinian territory has shrunk over
and over and over and over and over
again there was no independent state of
Palestine in this area did not exist to
these 67 and 47 borders were rejected by
the Palestinians not by the Jews and
third they are shifting the standard by
which they draw the border for 2020 okay
so that's just the facts of it by the
way you could draw this exact opposite
map but actually be realistic about the
amount of land that was promised to the
Jews originally it could show the amount
of the land promised to the Jews in 1917
including all of Jordan that you can
watch it gets sliced off because it was
sliced off in the British white papers
from the 1930s and then you can watch
the the 1947 borders appear and the
difference is in those maps Israel
accepted every single one of those deals
in order to have an independent Jewish
state the bottom lines of this conflict
there has never been a deal nor will
there ever be a deal so long as the
Palestinian leadership and the
Palestinian people do not change their
opinion about the existence of the State
of Israel Israel has accepted every
serious peace deal put before it since
before the inception of the state the
Arabs have never accepted a single one
not one that's the problem and so
anybody who suggests that the people who
continue to walk away from deals are the
are the innocence in all of this and the
people who continue to propose deals and
then unilaterally withdraw from
territory they are the problem that's
because you are determined to be
ignorant or you just have a problem with
Jews already we'll be back here a little
bit later today with two additional
hours of content or we'll be back here
tomorrow for your listening and viewing
pleasure you're listening to the Ben
Shapiro show
the Ben Shapiro show is produced by
Colton Haas directed by Mike joiner
executive producer Jeremy borin senior
producer Jonathan hey supervising
producer Mathis Glover and Robert
Stirling assistant director Pavel lie
down scoop technical producer Austin
Stephens playback and media operated by
Nick Sheehan associate producer Katie
Swinton edited by Adam SCI events audio
is mixed by Mike foramina hair and
makeup is by Nika Geneva the Ben Shapiro
show is a daily wire production
copyright daily wire 20 25 CNN's Don
Lemon makes an awkward on-air apology
for mocking half of his fellow
countrymen as ignorant illiterate rubes
the only problem with his apology is
that he never actually apologized we
will examine why being a leftist means
never having to say you're sorry then
the fate of impeachment comes down to a
nail-biter we take a look at the stakes
the Iowa caucuses are just four days
away and finally the mailbag check it
out on the Michael Doyle show
[Music]